"RISK
TSK."
"TIME" MAGAZINE IS IN THE NEWS,
WHICH IS RARE FOR A MAGAZINE
THESE DAYS.
THEY RAN A LIST OF THE
TOP TEN RISKS AND THREATS FACING
THE WORLD IN 2016.
FOR INSTANCE, WATCH OUT FOR
ISIS!
IN 2016.
GOOD REPORTING "TIME" MAGAZINE.
YOU'VE GOT MORE SCOOPS THAN
BASKIN-ROBBINS!
GOTTA SAY, OVERALL, THOSE ARE
SOME PRETTY BORING RISKS.
RISKS SHOULD BE RISKY, LIKE
GETTING YOUR BALLS WAXED AT
FANTASTIC SAM'S.
"GOTTA BE THE HAIR".
COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME
AS MANY ACTUAL RISKS TO THE
WORLD IN 2016 AS YOU CAN.
I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK. BEGIN.
>> COURTNEY LOVE IS ELIGIBLE
FOR THE ROCK-N-ROLL HALL OF
FAME.
>> OH, POINTS.
Chris: MICHAELA.
>> I MIGHT NEVER BE A MEMBER OF
TAYLOR SWIFT'S SQUAD.
>> Chris: JONAH.
>> TRUE DETECTIVE 3.
>> AMANDA BYNES RE-APPEARS AND
SEES HER SHADOW, SIX MORE WEEKS
OF WINTER.
>> Chris: JONAH.
>> I'M AT RISK OF TELLING PEOPLE
THAT [BEEP] DIES IN THE NEW STAR
WARS.
I DID IT.
>> Chris: OH!
>> HEY, YOU HAVE HAVEN'T SEEN IT
YET [BEEP] YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT -- THE MOVIE HAS
BEEN OUT FOR WEEKS.
IT'S MADE ALMOST A BILLION
DOLLARS.
CATCH UP OR SHUT UP!